So we said this works for any right triangle. We can square the leg, square
another leg, and add those together to get the hypotenuse squared. But, why
does this work? Well, let's see this by starting off with a square. Here's one
large square, and then this small square has a side length of a, and this
larger square has a side length of b. So, we know that the area of this square
is a squared. And the area of this square is b squared. And now, what I'm
going to do is break this white space up into four congruent rectangles. If
this length is a, then we know that this length is also a. And we know if this
length is b, then this length is also b. If our entire shape is a square, then
we know that if this side is a plus b, then this side must also be a plus b.
That's how we know that this side length is b. We can use the same reasoning to
say that this side length here, is a. Since we know the entire side must be a
plus b. So, notice that all four of these triangles are identical. They all
have a leg of a, a leg of b, and a hypotenuse of c. The four triangles are just
oriented in different ways. Like for this one, here's a, here's b, and here's
they hypotenuse across the 90 degree angle c. So now what we're going to do is
take this triangle and fix it at this point. We're going to rotate the triangle
around this point. We're also going to take this triangle here and fix it at
this point. So we can rotate the triangle around this point. So let's move
these two triangles to a different position. We're going to swing this triangle
up, around this point, and we're going to swing this triangle down, around this
point. When we rearrange the triangles, we get this new arrangement. Notice
that I have the same four triangles, with legs a and b, and a hypotenuse of c,
and the area inside here is c squared. So, what do we know must be true about
this area and this new area? Take some time to think and then fill in the
missing statements to this sentence. Choose one of these statements to make
this sentence true. And then, check any of these boxes that provide the correct
reasoning.